you did a show recently and and you grew
a beard for godless and I take a look at
this beard ladies and gentlemen I love a
good beard now damn it all that's a
man's beard that is that is an a hab
whaling captain here I have did you like
having that beard I did I did you know
you know there's this kind of just you
know you can hide things in it and all
that stuff but I just like that all that
stuff you get to play with it you get
the I liked it yeah yeah and it was
initially they said just a quarter-inch
that's all we want and I showed up with
that and they said keep that keep keep
that yeah and that probably it was that
like just one day of not shaving that's
pretty much that was about four months
that's pretty good months that's pretty
good yeah I had a beard when we went on
tour during our transition period and
people liked the beard my kids hated it
did you did your relatives like the
beard my mother hated the beard because
my mother feels that I should look
presentable at all times
I should never look like that right
which to which I say you know yeah I may
need a beard so I'm gonna let the hair
grow let the beard come out I could
always cut it and she's well he look
like you're homeless yeah okay all right
it's not nice and ver to say that
you